did you know that the hero of Black
Clover Asta may be directly related to
the time double asteroth the only one of
the three strongest Devils that still
hasn't been revealed because wizard King
Julius is connected to Thai magic and
because he's known about lucius's master
plan for many years there's a theory
that Julia secretly used lucius's Soul
magic to split asteroth's Soul into two
and these two parts are Asta and liebe
this is why the two of them look so much
alike this is why Asta was able to
survive inside his mother's womb even
though her magic drains both magic and
life force and this is why Asta was born
without magic his true magic is time
magic but Julius separated it from him
at least for now there's also the theory
that asteroth is actually asta's dad
which would be crazy subscribe to anime
outpro for more oh and